the title of today's webinar is using
blasts well and I'm pleased to Purdue to
present Tom Madden who's the lead of our
last team here at NCBI and I'm going to
turn it over to Tom now okay great
thanks Peter so this is Tom Madden and
so let me get just give you a little bit
of background on this webinar as I had
originally written up this as a talk for
hackathon that we had here at the NIH
about a month ago and so it was well
received and then we had some other
ideas so it modified it a bit and we're
using for the webinar since it was for a
hackathon it was actually kind of
centered around targeted to standalone
blast plus users and so thats as opposed
to people who come to the webpage to run
blast but if you've never run standalone
blast let me let me first say what that
is that basically means that you
download our executables from the FTP
site or somebody's installed on your
machine you go to a command line and you
type something to run them and I'll have
some examples of that later on if you've
never done that you may still find this
interesting because I'm gonna talk about
the some of the blast databases and what
they contain anyway so I let me get
going in hopefully you'll find is
interesting so this is the kind of the
first what I call a boilerplate slide
that you know what is blast I assume
that most people are familiar with you
know at least the basics of what blas is
supposed to do the main idea is it
calculates similarity between video for
biological sequences and you get your
query and you scan a database and look
for similar sequences and then you can
decide whether or not those similar
sequences are actually homologous it's
pretty fast it uses statistical theory
to help you determine if the match might
have occurred by chance so first I'm
going to turn and talk about the
different databases we have our database
descriptions can actually be kind of
confusing and this is something that we
actually need to work on is and maybe
having doing only a better job of this
but there are two main databases like we
look at that people often use and one is
the non-redundant protein database
called NR and this is basically our
largest collection of proteins and it
gives you proteins from like GenBank
CTS's and PDB and Swiss Pro and
everything though it excludes
environmental samples from WGS and we it
also excludes patent sequences and those
are actually searchable separately in
separate databases and the other
database that a lot of people search is
the nucleotide and t1 and that's got a
collection of a lot of different
nucleotide sequences you know it does
exclude some of these like est s and s
TS and GS s in a whole bunch of other
sequences that also excludes all these
assembled genomes like the human genome
and mouse genome and that's actually
something that you can insert separately
and so that's it's important to really
realize what's what's in these databases
as you go looking at them so as I said
it can be kind of confusing and so one
one way to look at this is with a Venn
diagram and I'm thinking you know if a
picture's worth a thousand words
you know Venn diagrams worth ten
thousand and so what we have is is we
have the in this on the left here if you
can can I see my mouse here or a pointer
okay so I guess you can see my mouse so
this left large circle here is the NR
non-redundant database and inside of Nan
NR
it includes a few other databases and
there's a rest seek protein which is
just sequences that have been annotated
here at the ncbi have better annotation
and they've been a little bit more
validation it's been done on them also
included as a swiss pro sequences and so
if you're probably familiar with swiss
pro it's a smaller database but those
are actually very well curated and
inside a rusty protein is also the
landmark database which is a which we
use
for smartblast and that's a set of
proteomes from I think it's 26 different
organisms and so that kind of gives you
a very non redundant spread out set and
then on top of that is PDB and those are
those are sequences with associated pdb
structures and and so these are the
sizes all not really to scale they just
kind of give you an idea of what things
are is like example resi is about half
of NR so it's actually pretty large and
I just kind of drew this here that Swiss
Pro probably a lot of the sequences in
Swiss Pro do overlap with refseq and
maybe they overlap my more like a
hundred percent I'm not sure I do know
that landmark is completely enclosed
within row seek the other independent
databases are there's a database of
metagenomic proteins and this basically
allow these come from WGS transcriptome
shotgun assembly proteins in Patton so
oh actually before I move on here let's
just say that NR so that this big NR has
171 million sequences and 63 billion
residues that's billion with a B so
that's actually pretty large refseq is
118 million sequences and 63 I'm sorry
45 billion residues so actually Resik is
a substantial fraction of NR Swiss Pro
has four hundred seventy thousand
sequences and 178 million residues and
landmark as it showed as they show you
here is pretty pretty small so so one
question is why do I search these and
you can think of this as like a use case
why would people want to run a search
against NR as opposed to rustic protein
or landmark you know and so the way you
think about NR the non-redundant one is
it's almost all the proteins at the NCBI
and you might be looking for homologs
and other organized
you got a protein you kind of look for
homologues and other organisms or maybe
you just want to identify your protein i
I don't know what protein is on your
search against at the ncbi refseq
protein so it's basically the same task
except you've got well curated proteins
and rusty so there you might again
search for home blogs and other
organisms and you might just identify a
protein on the other hand landmark is
only got 26 i think it's twenty three or
twenty six different organisms spread
across a great taxonomic range and so
what that will allow you to do is kind
of find homologs and distantly related
model organisms that represent a wide
range of taxonomic groups so these are
not necessarily all the use cases that
you could have for a database and if
you're not doing exactly this it doesn't
mean that you're doing something wrong
and if you'd like to actually share in
the box what kind of use cases that you
have for protein databases or the
nucleotide databases and we have time we
could actually go through a few of those
and that might be interesting for other
people listening to this to hear what
how people are using these databases
might be interesting for me too and it
says at the bottom here is not an
exhaustive list so moving on to the
nucleotide databases there's actually
it's a lot more confusing in a way so
here you have the nucleotide which we
talked I talked about earlier and so
this is about 48 million sequences in
two hundred billion bases so that's
substantial and inside of it is then the
refseq RNA and that's 23 million
sequences and 57 billion bases so that's
about a third or so the size of n T and
the and then we have this smaller 16s
ribosomal sequences and and so I'm going
to come back and tell you a little bit
more about what these are for but the
16s is um well curated sequences that
you can actually use you'd like for
example you know verifier
taxonomy of your sequences so we have
this group over here on the left and
then over here we have this massive set
which is refseq genomes and this is
basically all the genomes that are in
Rustique at the ncbi
and that's going to include mostly
eukaryotic genomes you know human genome
mouse genome and I just put down here
many other genomes but that's also going
to have likes and you know alligator
genome crocodile genome and so in the
right and so this this ends up being a
very large set within a set of rusick
genomes we have what we call
representative genomes and that gives
you just rather than giving you
redundant sets of genomes it gives you
the one best genome that we think is
representative and so that would mean
that rather than having like three
copies of the human genome and there's
probably more than that now is that you
just have the one within the
representative genomes outside of this
is then the other things like expressed
sequence tags es T's patent again we've
separated patent out again just because
most and actually that the rationale for
that is that most scientists aren't
really that interested in seeing the
patent records because they're not
really they don't have a lot of
scientific information on them and if
you're really interested in patents then
you're probably not going to be
interested in all the all these other
sequences over here and so in there's
also some older sets of databases like
high-throughput genomic sequences phases
0 1 & 2 these are really popular about
20 years ago when the human genome was
being assembled and since then that's
you don't get a lot of additions to HD
GS or est anymore so then they're not my
thing is they're not really that
interesting because they're not going to
have the newest greatest sequences in
them and then on top of that we also
have blast through the web page and also
through some standalone executables
offers you the whole genome sequences
and
I can't even tell you how the large set
is it's very large as well as SRA which
is the NCBI sequence read archive and
and so at least for I know for SRA they
measure this in the talk about petabytes
and peda basis and WGS is also um not
small so again let's look at some of the
use cases for nucleotide databases and
what we see people doing with NT this is
largest nucleotide databases you know
maybe they're gonna verify the identity
of some DNA that mean I've just
sequenced something I think I know what
it is and I just want to verify it real
quick I might have the case that I
really need to identify the DNA and so I
have some you know I've done some
sequencing run I've got a lot of DNA and
I just want to run it and see what each
of these M sequences are part of so
refseq RNA as it says here you know as
it implies these are RNA mRNA s and
other RNAs and these are curated
provided by the rusty group at the NCBI
and for this you could identify for
example unknown mRNA transcripts you
could identify coding regions on genomic
sequences you could look for other you
know RNA types of sequence the 16s
database that I talked about this this
ribosomal database this is actually very
useful because it allows you to classify
the taxonomy is sequences and samples
and this data has actually been
maintained here at the NCBI so we're
pretty sure the taxonomy and we think
that's pretty reliable and it also
allows you to validate the quality of
the sequences for example if for miss
assemblies or contamination or such and
so finally there's these other sequences
that we talked about like the like for
example the human genome you know and so
question might be is when do I use NT
when do I use the human genome and for
the human genome this is going to be the
case as well I wanna I've got a gene I
want to find a gene on the specific
genome here and that would be like the
case over blast n or T blast n so blast
n would take a nucleotide query and
blast
the human genome and actually I'm sorry
T blastin doesn't apply here and that's
that's wrong okay and the other cases I
might you know map weeds to a genome
with this new program we call magic
glasses this place where a liner I'll
mention that later on so as I mentioned
before and he's pretty large about 200
billion bases refseq is about RNA is
about 57 billion bases and the 16s is
like 30 million bases so the other two
were bees and 16s is a is an M and a
human genome of course is um stays at 3
billion bases and I think I mentioned
that the if we go up here just to be
clear then this refseq genome here is
about 1.2 tara bases so i guess it's
some trillion bases right so that that's
actually very large so now I want to
switch gears a little bit I've kind of
gone over some of the databases and then
switch to gears and talk about blast
parameters um and this is something that
people have found confusing in the past
and row probably find confusing the
future and so that's why I want to
address it there are a large number of
lance parameters a lot of them have to
do with some sort of algorithmic tuning
and most of those you can just leave a
loan that they've kind of in tune for a
good good default and so I would not
most of those I would not change there's
also on the standalone there's this task
parameter that you can set and so by the
task parameter targets your search to a
specific use case for example - tasks a
blast n gives you a word size of 11 and
a pretty sensitive search whereas the -
task of mega blast invokes the greedy
mega blast alignments and that has the
initial word size of 28 meaning I need
an exact match at 28 letters
do anything and then uses a method of
extension it's generally speaking it's
faster and but less sensitive but often
it does the job on blastp
there's a you do a task a - task of
blastp which is kind of the standard
blastp search that was on net people
have known about for quite a while and
first came out in 97 and then there's
also a blastp - fast which is still
pretty sensitive but uses a larger word
size and a compressed alphabet to do the
search actually faster so so those are
kinda good that that's actually a good
way to approach the problem is by saying
that - tasks flag there are other
parameters I would encourage people to
look at for example there's the expect
value and now if you're not familiar
with an expect value I'm just going to
see real quick what it is and so
generally so expect are you lower is
better that means a lower expect it's
kind of like a p-value and the lower it
is the better it is
it's a the default is and so think of it
as a false positive rate and what tells
you is it's the number of hits equal to
or greater than the score expected to
arise by chance if that last sentence is
a little bit long to remember just think
of lowers better a false positive right
and the default now is 10 which is
actually a little bit high for most
searches and that just says that if
you've got an expect value of 10 that
you probably got 10 results in there
that just arose by chance and often you
want to lower their expect value to 0.1
or 10 to minus 5 or it might even be 10
to the minus 30 it depends upon really
what you're going to do with the results
if you want to make sure you get a lot
of results and that you've got stuff to
kind of comb through and look at and and
maybe think about what's the now people
call the twilight zone where it's not
really clear whether this is a real
homolog or or just kind of some sort of
artifact then you know maybe you want to
go to to zero point one and zero point
one on the other hand if you have a
pipeline and you're just want to make
sure that these are really strong
matches and you've got hundreds of
thousands or millions of sequences then
you probably want a pretty low expect
value to prevent you from getting you
know false positives and okay so other
parameters that you might want to look
at things like the word size and I had
mentioned this before with them the task
is blast and the default is 11 and so
that means that you need 11 faces that
match exactly before you do anything
with a between two sequences so the two
sequences have to have 11 bases matching
exactly and for mega blast that's 28
which makes mega blast less sensitive
but on the other hand the databases as
we talked about are actually pretty big
so a mega blast search with 28 a lot of
mRNAs you'll probably get if a fair
number of hits and you may get all the
information you ever need if you're
running the kind of getting on the
standard blast report you can change the
number of descriptions or the number of
alignments you can also change the the
what we call max target seeks for like a
tabular or XML and Jason you know I'll
be showing you examples of these formats
a little bit but before I do that I want
to kind of go back and and talk about
something that you know people have been
discussing recently on Twitter and other
places is that so I've got my search
here right and so I'm running blast down
and this is the default task for
blasting is actually mega blast 9i so
this is really a mega blast run and I'm
running against NT there's 200 billion
bases I got my query and it's part of an
e.coli sequence I said a pretty low
expect value you know ten minus six and
I said I just want to see one match max
target sequences one
I want to see the first hit that blast
finds and this is a way of getting
tabular output and so I can say out
format and you know so I want to see the
crew accession the database accession
let's start in the end of the database
sequence expect value of the mash bits
core scientific name and title and we
got some documentation on this and I'll
go through some other examples of this
out format here but the main thing is is
that if you run it you get one match
you've asked blast to give you one match
so it gives you that
and so the III name this the query
e.coli and this is the accession of the
database sequence and so what do we got
here so and this just says that the
match starts down here and so that three
point is that three point nine million I
guess and goes onto here and it has a
you know expect value of basically of
zero which means that it's you know I
think means this below 10 to the minus
180 is in very small a large bit score
so it means it's high the organism is
e.coli and then the the title here is
isolate and q3 chromosome complete
genome okay very good so I put this in
here I've got one e coli match I'm done
this is the only best result but let's
go back and look at this run down here
and I've done the same run except rather
than asking max target sequences one I
say max target sequences 10 so I want to
see 10 matches so this gives me more to
look at but maybe it's a little bit more
revealing and it depends upon what I
want and so I'm seeing I get my 10
matches and the interesting thing here
is that the okay that's the max target
sequence 1 and that's 10 and so the
interesting thing here is I actually
have 5 matches with the same score so
they're all equivalent and really
there's no way to say that one is better
than the other as far as blast is
concerned now these are all
all ecoli so it's a you know and so
maybe doesn't make any difference to you
depending upon your use case you say
well yeah this is e : I'm happy with
that there there might be other examples
you find where like maybe one of the
e.coli strains is pathogenic or maybe
it's actually matches exactly with some
other bacteria so so that's a question
is that by just looking at the first one
you're actually throwing away some of
this information and so here you see
that there's basically different strains
are listed here and so you've lost that
information by only looking at one now
of course it depends upon what you're
looking to do with this whether you
whether you can be satisfied with just
one or maybe you want to go for a few
and double-check that and so this is
this is actually I'm kind of the dangers
of just looking at one match so now
switching gears a little bit I want to
talk about kind of different kinds of
reports that you can produce and so this
since this talk is geared towards
standalone blast plus I'm going to kind
of go through different reports that are
easier to parse and that people might
find useful when they're running blast
especially as part of a pipeline so the
first one here is the standard blast
report it's been around for a long time
this is actually the command line that
produces this blast report and so you
see here blast n the database is rusty
RNA the query is U 0 0 0 1 you know I
put it in fast a here and I'm just
taking the first 40 lines here if you're
familiar with with UNIX or Linux head
just means give me the first 40 lines in
the output and so ok so we see a
reference we see the name in the
database we see the query and what the
query is the length of the query in
these different meshes that are you know
produce significant alignments meaning
statistically significant the bit scores
over here and there you see the e value
and use notice that all these evaluate
our thorough just be
there's a lot of different copies of
this mRNA in there refseq RNA database
so and even though this is megawatt
running in megablast mode here there is
absolutely no problem of finding lots of
results but so this report is designed
to be human readable it's subject to
change and so we do not encourage you to
parse it and that's actually why we
produce some other formats that we are
easier to parse and provide better
support for that so one of the one that
people actually like a lot is the
so-called tabular report and so here is
the command line here that shows you how
to to run this and to produce this out
what we use - out format seven and so
it's going to give me the the default
tabular report which is you know the
query and the subject and the percent
identity and some other information you
can look at the main thing being you
know here you have expect value that you
saw on the normal Blas report here you
have the bit scores and it kind of gives
you the start and stop of the matches so
if you can actually go through and parse
this and say oh well my query match
these database sequences starting here
to there and that's um and maybe I'm
gonna go pick this out and look at it
some more or okay so this is simple to
parse it's nice now if this is not all
the information people ever want out of
blast and so that's why we have you can
customize the tabular report and so to
do that it's out format seven and queer
accession subject accession length which
means the subject the length of the
alignment and then this is the subject
length and so this is actually giving
you pretty basic information it's not
giving you the expect value it's not
giving you the bit score and so you see
here this is queer all the time these
are different database sequences and
these are
the lengths of the the database sequence
I'm sorry these are the lengths of the
alignment and then these are the lengths
of the database sequences now for
example you could write an ox script
that would just parse this and take a
you know divide you know this length by
that length and tell you you know how
much of your subject sequence was
actually covered by your query or how
much of your subject sequence is
actually covered by the alignment
because maybe you want matches that
cover most of the subject sequence
something else you can do is you can go
for taxonomy and so this is the same
thing here of query accession subject
accession disk the scientific name and
then the common name and that's for the
subject sequence in both cases and so
you see here well this is Homo sapiens
human human this is you know pygmy
chimpanzee chimpanzee and so this kind
of goes down and gives you taxonomy
information without telling you you know
of course you're not looking at expect
value or bit score here you could
actually print those out here but I just
didn't bother to keep it simple but so
this gives you specialized taxonomy
information do the same thing CSV comma
separated value and then you should be
able to UM upload that pull it into
Excel or maybe parse it in some other
way and so that gives you a lot of
flexibility something else that people
have liked has been that the jason and
and what so this is just a it's kind of
like i think this is a blast report in
in jason and so here for example here
you see the reference up here see some
of the parameter information a query ID
if you go down here then you're seeing
the the information about your first
match
you know the ID the accession nine six
oh six it means that it's human and so
the tax ID the NCBI taxonomy group
assigns the tax ID to every node in
taxonomy tree
and for human is nine six oh six and
that's just a convenient way of
referring you know at least in programs
of referring back to a specific node and
in taxonomy tree and so this is actually
giving you a lot of information here
that you can in an easily possible way
for example Jason you probably run a
Python script load it in and parse this
out pretty quickly and basically it we
have an XML format that is the same
thing and then one common is is that is
you might have no we are the NCBI is
moving away from GRS and towards
accessions so I I would suggest that you
just stick with the accessions here
rather than getting stuck on the GIS
that may disappear from you okay oh and
this is sorry this is output format 15
and this is the command line up here so
there's a so I've showed you a bunch of
different reports and you could imagine
they have different uses for example I
run blast I want to get a tabular report
I just want to see and I only want to
look at matches that cover my query you
know have a certain coverage over my
query or maybe have a certain taxonomy
or you know a certain bit score and then
if they reach some threshold maybe I
want to go back and look at this
manually the other one is I'm just going
to discard this or you know and so this
this would almost indicate that you need
to run blast multiple times but that's
actually not the case because blast has
something you can run at once and then
you can you know enjoy your results so
to speak many times for the last
formatter and so this is an example this
is the command line I would run for
blast in and this is the database refseq
RNA the query out format 11 and it
produces blast archive format and then
the blast formatter which is a separate
program can read in this file here and
it can format it as requested and for
example this is out format 7 the
standard tabular form
you could do this you know basically all
the examples I showed you earlier so you
could you know run this one right here
and if you decide that these um the
length of the alignment was long enough
for overcame some threshold and thought
that was really interesting to look at
then you could go down and you could
just look at a you could spit out a
standard Blas report and so that back
gives you a lot of flexibility shifting
gear again and hopefully I'm not doing
too bad in time but I want to talk a bit
about taxonomic limits it can clear the
clutter meaning I got a lot of results
and maybe I don't want to see them all
maybe I only want to see the human
results or maybe I don't want to see the
human results maybe I only want to see
bacterial results and it runs faster in
general at least because the you've got
less of a database to search and so
here's an example
I've got refseq protein I've got this
human protein here and I'm searching
against rusty protein I've limited the
human and so I see then that all these
well first of all all these matches say
human here right and you see that I've
got different components different
isoforms so I've got a lot of variety
and so these two proteins are related
but I'm really getting all the different
isoforms and this is all the results I
get I get 12 results here and so that's
actually great because I can look
through those and if I'm interested in
different isoforms then now I know I
have that information now if I do the
same thing without a limit um you know
its first of all it's 507 hits so you're
not seeing all the hits here I'm seeing
from different organisms
you know from gorilla and chimpanzee and
what's different here also is really I
only seem to be seeing one one version
of the protein one isoform here they all
say component a to component a - so this
is actually a different use case I've
got one protein one
form I want to see you know how it
appears in all kinds of different
organisms maybe I want to make a tree
with this maybe I want to find out if
this you know this isuh form which
organisms it appears in so that's kind
of a different use case so we recently
hasn't made some enhancements to help
people limit the search by taxonomy and
so we're calling this blast TV version 5
you know I apologize for the programmers
speak in the reason it's called version
5 is because the current version of the
last databases version 4 and but what it
lets you do is limit your search by
taxonomy with a command line parameter
and the taxonomy information is built
into the database in a way that we can
use it to limit your search it improves
your perform well can the other thing
about class to be version 5 is it
improves your performance when living a
blast search with accessions or
retrieving my accession and this is
important as the NCBI moves from GIS
which are numbers to accessions you can
also retrieve sequences by taxonomy from
the blast database it works with the
newest version of blast plus which was a
maiden alpha release several months ago
but we're gonna have a an upcoming
release and hopefully this month Peter
did a webinar on this a couple actually
several months ago I guess and so
there's the youtube link there and then
there's some documentation here that you
can get to and since these slides are
available you can get to those
so moving on here so I'm going to tell
you a little bit about magic blast you
know it's a splice aware a liner it's
based on the the magic on the aligner
and the magic pipeline John and Danielle
Jeremy has made and we've reimplemented
that with a blast toolkit it uses
plaster bases to do its mapping it's
some especially good with longer
sequences and so this is a and we have
an article actually in or we have a
preprint
I guess you call it and bio archive and
that we'll be submitting to a journal
soon but so this is a figure from that
preprint and so this is a set that we
made up it's the that the reads are
based on the rustic annotation and so
that we actually know what the results
really should be like and in magic glass
was not used in the rustic annotation so
there's it's not a circular logic here
but you can see that with them magic
glass for these longer sequences we do
pretty well perfect matches is you know
97.2% and some partial and some
misaligned and so with compared against
high set to with some relaxed parameters
high set to star long and the older top
hat too so real quick because I think I
probably run out of my time this is the
blast web page you know you can see the
Euro at the top you can download
standalone blast here down the bottom
there and there's a over here in the
right corner you can see where there's
some help that you can get and we also
have an ami in you know Amazon machine
image at AWS that you can run and you
can get it from there
so resources some of the resources for
command-line options and these are
actually the appendices in the blast
manual and so this is a several tables
of the command-line options you can go
and look at them and the read there's
another appendix about rewarding
mismatched panel fees and this applies
for blast and mega blast available
scoring matrices and this is more blastp
blast X and then there's a link to the
magic blast article we run okay and so I
guess this is the so after this is a few
more slides that we're not going to go
into that's an appendix that called the
hidden life of the last database and we
just didn't have time for that but if
you want to take a look at then you're
welcome to it
okay this is Peter Cooper again we have
a lot of questions more than I think
I've ever seen in a webinar before to be
honest with you which is good
um many of these are sort of detailed
questions about how do I do a particular
task I think it's I can't even answer
those right now because I have to go
look at certain things and give you the
correct
you know exact laundry queries and
things like that so for those things
I've answered some of them in the chat
but I haven't been able to answer all of
them I will make a document with the
answers to those so I'll post that and
pass it off to everybody the one thing
that's come up several times because I
think it's was sort of announced ahead
of time that Tom might be able to
discuss this a little more was the next
target sequence letter that was in
bioinformatics this is where it was yeah
yeah so there's a lot of confusion about
that and I guess what there are several
questions in the chat pod about that and
I guess what people want to know is what
is the effect of Mac's target sequences
and what's the recommendation for how
they should use that parameter and and
how does it affect what results they see
back in other words it's clear from
reading the questions that many people
believe that it shows you the first
match it finds rather than the best one
which I don't think is true but I'll let
you address that if you don't mind okay
thanks Peter
so yeah so blast goes through the goes
through the database looking for the
best matches collects those and then
presents them to you and and I kind of
um can I go back go back here so and
this is um you know starting to address
it here limiting output to one match so
so what Blas does is it goes to your
database finds the best mashes ranks in
my score and expect value and so in this
case and the bottom set there's you know
five matches that are basically
equivalent and blast can't say that one
is better than the other so it does show
you the user the if you just say I want
to see one and show you the top one so
and now even if you say I only want to
see one blast is still going to go
through the entire database it's still
going to collect these five matches it
actually collects a few more matches
than a you know
actually many more matches than it
presents to you because and this is just
part of the algorithm to make sure that
we don't miss stuff or to make it very
unlikely we miss stuff so there had been
the question max target sequences one in
you know when I think about it I would
you know generally recommend that you
yeah you probably want to look at more
than one sequence again it depends upon
your use case in this case I attend and
I saw a bunch that were the same so
maybe if you don't want to look at a lot
then 10 is a is a good number
I would probably shy away from 1 unless
you have the case like that any hit at
all
is going to that you want to that you're
only interested if there's any match at
all and so something that comes to my
mind and maybe people have other
examples would be is um say I've
sequence some done some bacterial
sequencing I know that the results
should be bacterial but they've been
done by humans and I wanna make sure
that there's no human DNA involved in
the ER that I didn't somehow contaminate
it with my own DNA DNA so I take my
sequences and I run them against the
human database and any match then it's
going to be disqualifying for this read
and I'm gonna you know for this query
and I'm just gonna throw it away because
this contamination so so that's an
example I think we're maybe max target
sequences one would be okay but
generally I think you want to go through
several and like Peter said is that
there is some confusion about how blast
blast goes through the database it does
go through all the database collections
all the matches
there is a example that you could you
know and and in this letter that he
mentioned there there wasn't the example
that I really wanted to see and I kind
of need to see command-line parameters
and such but you could imagine that I
take all the sequences in the database
Irie order them and maybe blast will
give me a different top match and maybe
instead of if I were to take my database
and reorder it maybe I get this second
match here instead the first one so it's
it's the same you know it's the same
significance
and and blasters have some tiebreaking
logic in it to help people that's kind
of getting into technical details again
really go to right now so I you know so
that's basically my point of view is
when I think about it and I and I hadn't
really thought about until like the last
week is if you know max target sequences
one it's generally speaking not a great
choice okay thanks Tom would you put
that last slide back up just because
yeah yeah the last slide that was in the
deck because basically we're out of time
and I there are lots of good questions
in here and I just want to point out
that on the last slide there are some
useful links the you know people are
asking me stuff about command-line
parameters and things like that those
things are addressed in the manual and
then the help Docs a lot of times so
take a look there and if you ever have a
question like many of the questions that
came in and chat pod right to blast help
blast up was an email address it's on
this slide here blast - help at NCBI dot
in lnh a gov and we will answer your
question I just couldn't get to all the
ones that we got in the chat pod didn't
have questions pod today but I will put
those in a document and I will make them
available and I'll send you a link to it
as soon as I have it ready so I want to
thank everybody for coming it's about
quarter to one which is what we said
this was a forty-five minute webinar so
we're going to stop there and thanks
everyone and we'll see you next time